this all confining the kids leads to
what here's a daily mail story party
like it's 2019. florida and fort
lauderdale expects triple the amount of
visitors over the last years tens of
thousands prepared to celebrate the
first spring break in the u.s free of
covet rules thousands of college
students and visitors are descending on
florida's beaches not california but
florida this week to celebrate the first
spring break without any coronavirus
restrictions since 2019 inhabitants of
popular vacation spots including cancun
miami pensacola fort lauderdale the
south padre island have to deal with
observing never-ending crowds of college
students having a good time often
blasting loud music and drinking alcohol
from the first week of march until april
starting on saturday until march 20th
many public schools districts in florida
including pan uh penn uh pennios
hillsborough pasco et cetera et cetera
as well as the last university of
southern florida and tap on will be on
vacation last year spring break saw 65
000 passengers fly into tampa bay
international airport per day during
peak weeks however in 2020 the number of
spring breakers was dismally low in
march and april as there were fewer than
1500 flights a day versus 65
foul so people are about to start
partying in
florida you're around college students a
lot what do you think about the story i
think my youngest sister who i mentioned
before who is a sophomore in college
she's a college basketball player she
came with me down here she said oh
you're going to fort lauderdale that's a
free spring break trip for me so um
she's here although i hope some of that
debauchery that you described she won't
be taking part in
um if she does i'll just you know make
her babysit i mean it's it's great in a
sense i'm not i'm not endorsing some of
the spring break footage that we see out
of florida every year but it's great
that people young people specifically
who are so prone to be vulnerable to the
fear that we were talking about with
climate change are realizing that they
don't have to be afraid of kovid they
don't have to be they don't have to stop
their lives anymore they don't have to
not associate with other people they can
just do their thing they can go to
school again they can go party again
they can go on spring break again that's
a good thing and florida of course has
been a leader a leader in uh following
the science on the coveted regulations
it's it's that's why i've come to
florida so many times in the past year
just to get away from get away from some
of the policies in a blue state but um
it's good i i was really encouraged too
to hear the surgeon general of florida
say that they're not going to encourage
vaccines covered vaccines for healthy
children that's what the science says
that's that's that's really nice
you said yeah she called him a
politician
yeah so they asked her
propagating conspiracies yeah what do
you think about florida you know
uh not uh
agreeing with kids taking the vaccine uh
do you agree with them absolutely not
what's your answer absolutely the
science we have the science the true
science and the true science tells us
that you know vaccine for kids
uh anyway so yeah so that's what's gonna
found the way to say even death in the
next 90 seconds
three times
it's it's uh even death the currency of
fear is very effective it's worked for
centuries every you know it's been used
for so many years
and they're using it very eloquently but
people in florida especially with ron de
santa he's getting a lot of did you see
him uh the other day with the whole
masking with the kids
i don't appreciate you guys having a
mask on anyways if you're going to wear
it just you know yeah this mask okay
here you go so
good to be here in florida
did you see their faces when they took
the masks off though they thought there
was like one or two that were horrified
but the rest of them were like
yeah i saw that yeah but that's what
they need they need a strong leader to
tell them like it's okay to take your
face mask by the way things are going
about about to get very insane down here
in south florida now as a true
conservative i very rarely go visit
south beach and party past midnight
that's something i've definitely not
known to do
uh however the few times that i have
gone down to south beach during the day
over the last few years
like last year i went down and i and i
did a man on the street piece uh about
spring break stimulus spending and it
was i was interviewing all the people it
was a really sexy topic exactly and it
was just all the people that were
getting stimulus checks that were just
like where else are they gonna go
florida obviously these weren't
necessarily college kids at that time
there was just people getting stimulus
checks yo we're going to south beach
we're going to fort lauderdale about to
have the time of our lives that's going
to get amplified times 10. now it's like
you know gloves are off you know flights
are back we're going to party in south
beach so just be very
weary and uh hopefully your 19 year old
sister doesn't party too hard well i
disagree with the debauchery of spring
break i absolutely disagree with it
however it's very interesting that greg
abbott and ron desantis their states are
going to get tax revenue visitors and
local businesses are getting a lot of
patronage in the hospitality hotels
restaurants and things we're getting a
lot of dollars and florida and texas and
those entrepreneurs running those places
are cash what do you mean you disagree
with the debauchery first of all i
disagree with the debauchery but you've
got a but you have a wave of commerce
that's coming to ron desantis and greg
abbott first of all thanks to spring
break when tom's podcast gets started
his number one sponsor is gonna be a cbd
oil company yeah or a beer tom is gonna
say today's message is brought to you by
cbd oil from boca raton uh our friends
over here you know bring the best best
anyways going back to debauchery when i
was in the army okay
fourth of july we were at panama city
okay memorial day weekend panama city
you know
whatever labor day panama city in the
army they would call it the danza we
would come down here and it was an
incredible time incredible time we read
a lot of books we went to all the local
borders and barnes and norway we were
very committed
no drinking no fighting no girls nothing
yes it's going to be i have a feeling
it's going to be a bigger number than
they even expect it to be
which i'm sure you'll support that
because you probably can't wait to go
out there and speak down there with our
friend david doing some interviews at
model volleyball this weekend if you're
in south florida
come check us out what's her name shout
out to her father what's uh olivia ormos
my girl yeah she's putting together a
model if you're in south florida this
weekend be in south beach for model
volleyball it's going to be
epic but biz doc you're not invited
because it'll be a little too
debaucherous for your little taste okay
little guy all right so here we go
here we go he's gonna come back don't
worry just be patient so if you enjoyed
this little segment from the podcast
click over here to watch the entire
podcast and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please do so take care
everybody
[Music]